[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout s'est donc amusé huit ans quand
j'ai connu ma peau mais d'été purement
heureuse vous premier mouvement paralyse
le coût des ouailles
à l'époque à mon amoureux de l'époque à
utiliser des progrès du insultants et
humiliants bon à personne on renoncer
faute de l'otan il avait écoute tu es
trop imbu de sa personne tu es m'bolhi
trop fière de toi tu as la langue bien
pendue tu dois toujours là à mener et
donne et on a un titre
gérer une tendance ou quoi donc tu
devrais de considérer heureux et
chanceux d'avoir un homme qui peine qui
tu acceptes être connaissances en est
enchantée et semi
continue comme ça je suis sûr que tu
finiras ta vie tout seul et dans honey
de 7 ans à l'époque je suis dit il a de
l'expérience il assure en revenant ce
qu'il dit il faut que je change il faut
que le faire un travail sur moi même
j'ai d'andorre que par mes parents de
vous enlever de paix de poids
en une année et demie avec ma
nutritionniste et mon coach de woody
positive je suis passé de 120 kg 60 kg
et je ressemblais à peu près à ça wallah
n'ont su passer de sa race
incroyable les femmes de mon fait du bon
boulot
j'ai donc a perdu du poids ou encore et
compte un tant soit peu à cet idéal de
femmes dans la sphère de farine allait
tourner f-22 d'exception amoureux pas
bon que l'on ait des privés naïm que
j'étais à l'époque je pensais que les
fêtes les femmes mais ce ne se faisait
pas la nier elle ne connaissait pas de
déception amoureuse si le débat une
chose qu'il faisait partie de leurs
continuer à m avez vous déjà vécu une
situation pareille quelque chose qui
vient lui et ses oies protides y ait
quelque chose qui déséquilibrent paix
intérieure attaquera son que vous
décidez de changer mais changer par vos
pas pour votre bonheur mais changer ou
correspond un tant soit peu à cet idéal
à cette perfection pour montre c'était
un peu ce qui m'arrivait à l'époque une
halle et demi plus tard je me suis rendu
compte vers bien je suis humain mais pas
forcément plus heureuse donc vérifier la
théorie mettons en commun pour moi
comment ça allait se passer
je suis donc mise en couple à nouveau et
une année plus tard à la veille de
malchance le bon monsieur m'appelle mais
vital de chuter et me dit la rose en
voilà ces paroles je pense qu'il vaut
mieux qu'on arrête la relation jeu des
bois et dj trop mais tu es trop
à n'utiliser dans ses mots il a détenu
manque de piment la vie avec toi électro
au mieux ou est une fille une femme
d'être 12 est soumise mais c'est aussi
du caractère c'est aussi des opinions ce
que malheureusement toi tu n'as pas je
suis dit mais qu'est ce qui m'arrive
j'ai plutôt fait des efforts je peux tu
as essayé j'ai plutôt qu'à l'âge qui
était jouée maigrir moi même je te
remercie donc qu'est-ce qu'une bombe
soleil raconte est ce qu'il est normal
je commençais par une ex youn et je me
suis dit il doit y avoir
un pan de l'histoire qui m'échappe et
j'ai quand même
soutenu ma licence et l'année qui a
suivi j'avais enfin envie de continuer
de faire ma stature et c'est à la mode
des primes et à ne rien faire du tout la
seconde année pendant que je m'apprêtais
à commencer matters mes parents m'ont
dit non on a vu pendant une année des
primes et à la maison ici prendre cette
année car je les études peut battre tout
offrant un voyage tuera dans leurs nerfs
tu as trop longtemps durant reprennent
que râler je peux tu n'as jamais fait
mais que tu ne ferais plus comme aller
dans la nature lee voyager j'ai déjà
fort comme vous avez occupé
moi j'aimerais bien voyager donc mon
renvoi est loin du mot loyaux togo dans
une réserve au nord du togo et pendant
que je préparais ce voyage j'ai décidé
d'acheter des livres m'a fait une année
à bien faire la maison la
multifamiliales était devenu mon lieu
préféré de la maison qui me parlait donc
de me bourrer âge et pendant mes d'achat
le livre a attiré mon attention
dutil était révélateur dans ma situation
beaucoup le voient cm twilight et
meurent à comprendre sa douleur pour
entendre son désir de catherine bessette
jeu tu dis mais ça me parle elle est
déjà allée à la librairie et vous avez
vu dans les rayons livres qui vous a
inspiré un livre que vous avez eu envie
d'avoir en ce moment là c'était ça
j'avais pour lui de pousser des
souvenirs j'ai donc acheté de saré métal
dans la valider le fait pas tout une
fois sur place ça a été
les boules vexant pour moi ce livre a
changé ma vie et à changer la perception
que j'avais le ce que je devais faire
j'ai donc entrepris un voyage et la
confiance en soi j'ai décidé de reporter
et ma confiance en moi mais cette fois
ci selon mes principes cette fois-ci
j'allais faire des choses selon ce que
je pensais juste pour moi j'ai donc
commencé le voyage est géré de zouhair
en capital en premier lieu
je suis allé vers là que tu allais être
témoin de l'affairé du côlon en eau soit
social lourd mandat social était pour
moi le moment de me débarrasser de cette
dépendance vis à vis de la vie des
autres je peux dette du poids plus je me
rendais fondre au cht est devenu
dépendant de ce que les autres pensaient
pouvoir le petit compliment de rire de
tout tu as maigri tu a bonne mine
aujourd'hui tu es jolie c'était devenu
pour moi l'essentiel c'était de moi ma
raison de vivre en ce moment du parcours
c'était le moment pour moi d'arriver à
me détacher de ce compte de ce que
pensent de ce fait divers surtout ce que
les autres pensent juge ait beaucoup
après
cette étape jeudi à livrer une autre
étape de la plaie de la connaissance de
soi comme le dirait le naufrage pour
l'éclatement même ce n'est pas que moi
qui fait joli joli non c'est une
philosophie de vie il est important
pour que h à faire simple plutôt de
bacon à se connaître de connaissez
défaut de connaître ses talents et parce
que je le dis souvent
autant que nous sommes fait dans le plus
grand des réfections ces hormones sont
imparfaites exactement ce qu'on peut
appeler la perfection
le connais toi toi même c'était oman au
mois nous on est prêts qui réellement
simoneau qui elle est réellement selon
ses objectifs selon des principes selon
ce qui n'est pas nue et la fait vibrer
dans la vie après avoir effectué ce
petit détail si je suis allé vers
quelque chose de chapelet de la cour
l'europe de soi à ce niveau là il était
question de te pardonne l'arrivée parce
que pardonner pour le mal que nous
laissons les autres nous faire mais
également de se pardonner pour sept
jours une forme plus bas de
rambouillet le doute et que nous
laissons les mulets d'autres nous
désertons déséquilibré dans la paix
le
pardon ce soir c'est avant d'être
tolérant avec foi même à savoir que la
vie ne peut pas leur épreuve culinaire
est de fous non fonctionnement il doit y
avoir de faux sang et les jo afrique
c'est ce qui constitue équilibre de la
ligue
après sa voix a appris à me pardonner je
suis arrivé j'ai appris l'amour de soi
l'amour de soi quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
en tant qu une amoureuse de l'amour
l'amour de soi est
le moment de mon voyage et j'ai le plus
apprécié entre moment là il était
question d'aimer la personne les
extraordinaires que l'univers portez
vous savez qui se bat avec moi
la route soit en ce moment là c'est elle
le choisit me choisit dans les jours je
suis heureuse me choisit dans les choux
de fuite prive me choisit quant à
fabriquer des choses extraordinaires
comme l'e tron qui si aujourd'hui s'il
me choisit quand je n'ai envie de rien
que je me relevais du parti l'a mené
dans ma chambre à me laver comme
grossiste mais je passe devant le mur de
vidal g man et puis comme j'ai dû malgré
tout une belle fille quand même la moue
de soir
cette chose extraordinaire qui nous
permet d'être la première personne à
déterminer leur valeur la première
réaction à savoir ce que vaut réellement
et quand tu as compris que cette chose
magnifique qui est de savoir ce que tu
vaux réellement qui me donnait plus
distrait pas le bruit de fond
j'aimerais lui dirai pas ce que les
autres pensent de la valeur ou la voile
est culte donne
après avoir fait un arrêt sur le chemin
de ma faute sur fond noir j'ai découvert
l'univers de la confiance en soi il est
0 royal possibilité que par mon frère
est l'une de ces possibilités
est ce que j'ai appelé l'accessibilité
positive
un désespéré settled est négative
précieux de la black et à leur aile je
veux dire oui puis les successeurs et
négatives allez vous déjà vécu ce trauma
team qui est de dire oui pour rapporter
ciel alors que vous n'avez pas envie je
dois rouler des gentils opinion je dois
commencer dit alomar si oui vous devez
pratiquer la sexualité négative et il a
reçu dans votre confiance en vous avez
vous déjà nés c'est à les métiers aller
jusqu'à la fin
malgré que vous aviez malin malgré la
police eut été et confortable vous devez
jusqu'à la fin d'un possible effet la
toile est impossible de puiser
mais bordel en effet lancé à l'autre ça
la
fuite au moment des expérimentés dax
était négative et il ya eu une issue
dans votre chanson de route qu'est ce
que j'appelle dans la sexualité positive
lassitude est positif c'est ce rapport
d'amour qui nous entretenons avec notre
corps l'accession des positive c'est la
confiance en soi à mener dans les
timides et je dis souvent que l'aficion
deposit il cédera 100 degrés au lit en
hiver ou en la matière comme um nyobé
nez de votre vie c'est un peu mort où on
est peu votre l'épreuve du poids que le
vendredi soir le semblable que sa plume
à par andres pavon que au cfaa nouveau
plaint que d'autres hommes m'ont
complètement plat lcd positive est cette
chose qui vous permet de vous exprimer
librement dans l'intimité avec votre
partenaire et la csd positive vient dé
le moment que vous avez confiance en vos
contient 60 et celle des produits de mer
une fois que vous avez confiance on veut
prouver intérêts monter la cfl des pros
des tirs
je suis membre au sein et laissez moi
vos dé
l'argent soit cette chose qui me permet
de répondre oui pour un terme à la côte
et la première c'est que je fais parce
que je sais que j'ai quelque chose à
donner je sais que les gens n'ont plus
fait lui
sera impactée par ce que je dis la
confiance en soi est cette chose qui me
permet de rester focus sur metacritic de
me dit cette chose je peux le créer je
leur ai dit ça prendra le temps je jure
je vais elle choisit le chemin mais j'ai
la capacité en moi de le faire j'ai joué
une fois mr allam et unième je réussirai
à le faire passer de match laissait le
peu la confiance en soi est cette chose
qui me permet d'être ce capitaine a
vendu la vie de ma vie et toute personne
qui aurait l'audace ou le rêve des
capitelles à la fin son capitaine tu ne
cherches pas du bord
je suis mon dos à ce jour serait d'avoir
confiance en vous
parce que c'est la chose la plus
extraordinaire que vous pouvez
expérimenter dans la vie c'est le plus
beau cadeau que vous pourrez vous chers
vous allez faire 60 ans il a beaucoup de
chance elle vous allez passer ce coup là
dedans après la nouvelle elle va en
effet que le conflit est de nous mêmes
avec qui vous êtes alex et la ville de
jos où déséquilibré au thé point que
vous êtes incapable de faire sur quoi
vous avez pourtant la capacité
je suis mon chien elle je vous encourage
en france au pouvoir qui vous était
donné
si vous voyez l'europe univers là dans
les bois permet de prendre place de
brancher dissociable de la banque l
univers sons vous ce tableau en place
par six à sept milliards d'habitants sur
terre mais il ya une personne qui est
comme on
le dit souvent mon
salut à la tradition en disant bonjour à
tous et à toutes vous êtres humains
figurent cet après midi et je suis
heureux d'avoir partagé
ce que tu parles moi avec vous mais
[Applaudissements]